hey everybody
welcome back to another episode of the
unwaxed podcast here we are again
shooting in our kitchen sophia and i are
wearing
sweatpants and a nice top so if you
think that we look hot from
here down you were mistaken just 50
today 50 percent
effort but welcome back everybody to
unwax with their favorite sisters sophia
and sistine stallone
i'm still struggling um to be
professional and take this podcast
seriously when i'm sitting in my kitchen
i don't know there's something there's
such a loose element now
i feel like i'm slunching slouching
staring um a little bit of a
weekly update um sophia and i have been
recently
on the hunt for once
four apartments
know i'm gonna say don't take this
personal but i probably will
i was a little nervous
in the beginning to move in with you
you don't think i wasn't you weren't you
were
sophia we fight like cats and dogs oh
wait
we do we okay this is my thing in the
beginning
of the year when nicole kova thinks i
know we were
processing like making this show happen
we were like oil and water we still are
but we were just like
i'll tell you guys we because you know
we have different work
approaches we we approach creative
things differently
uh uh writing emails we say things
differently so
everything everything is different and i
feel like we just had this like back and
forth
all the time we just could not get to a
middle ground and we literally wouldn't
even like end the fight it would just be
like you know what
we cannot fight right now and just like
let's just work we're just working so
it's almost like we would have
i don't know if you guys have ever had
this where you'd be fighting with your
sibling
and you're just so over fighting you're
like i'm just gonna let i'm gonna push
this under the rug
like we're not gonna have any resolution
with this there's no like winner here
it's just you don't think that way
anymore right no so this is the thing
is that we have been looking for
apartments i think we both were a little
hesitant to find a place together
but lately we've been so i think
on the same wavelength do you want i'll
tell you why i kind of
i figured out why we've been getting
along so well because
it's not that we don't get along um but
we have not been fighting you know
siblings you always just bicker about
little things that hasn't been happening
and i think i figured out what it was i
was in bed the other day it was two
nights ago
and we had a really fun night two nights
ago and i was just sitting there i was
like
what what's the catalyst for us being so
nice to each
sophia and i as the joke got into a
full-blown wrestling match
but serious like kicking punching in the
stomach
i was dragging her by the feet across
the floor she was sitting on me
i had the dog on her feet dog was eating
my face
and then i realized i'm like maybe
that's how we get our anger out
we should just wrestle like once a month
oh i'm serious
i'm actually like i think we should like
physically fight not punching
hard yeah but
if this gets 30 000 uh listens then i
will upload the video
because we have a video of it we do have
a video of it so
no but i'm so excited not to live here
and you know what i have to just say
spending much more time with cysteine
there are so many things i'm learning
about you
like what no i don't want to say it but
like very personal things i've learned
about you i feel like you've learned
about me please tell me one
we can cut it if it's bad no i can't i
don't want to say it i can't say it
because it's personal
you can't but it's so rude to the
listeners you just drop an easter egg
like that and
i can't expose you i'm really saving
your ass if you want to be on it like
there's no
no it's just you know you guys
just spend time with your siblings
that's the right no
but basically where you're looking for
an apartment we're super stoked and if
you guys have ever seen the show
new girl i was just gonna say that
that's the oh my god
so basically if you guys know new girl
the show
it is so good let this be your next
quarantine binge
we love the aesthetic of the apartment
it's like a big
loft and the roommate situation so it's
really good
almost like the very character so sophie
and i are really trying to recreate the
show right now
so maybe we should put it on craigslist
like the show did and we get some new
roommates i don't know yeah so we're
looking for an apartment like that we've
got a pinterest board going which really
means
the shit's serious yeah if you have a
pinterest board going
so yeah we're really excited this whole
process i think um hopefully you guys
enjoy hearing about it and maybe we'll
like tell you a little update
every week about you know our findings
and
it's been fun i mean every morning i
send you apartments you send me
apartments we're like that's too
expensive
we're gonna have to pay for this so i
can't really drop too much
but it's been fun oh you know what we
did the other night that i thought was
so funny um we've seen just about every
tv show that's come out on hulu amazon
netflix i mean
we've seen so much tv it's almost
disturbing but we stumbled across um
tlc's show my strange addiction will
are you a watcher of this i have not
seen it unfortunately
i don't have you how do you have tlc
this is the age of streaming is that
like
okay it's on hulu
uh okay okay it's on hulu you need to
watch it
these people are insane there's so
basically they're all addicted to
something one is like
i'm addicted to eating my cat's hair i'm
addicted to
eating brick i'm addicted to eating baby
powder like crazy stuff right
eating like bread yeah yeah yeah so
it's insane there was one that we
watched it's crazy there's one that we
watch
of this woman who is addicted and in
love
with this what do you call like a fair
carnival ride like a roller coaster at a
carnival
and she goes as far as she has an
intimate relationship meaning she has
sex with a carnival ride
and she marries it so that's her husband
or her whatever you call significant
other
what the [ __ ] right i said sophia i was
thinking about it on the drive
i was driving the other that i was
thinking about i'm like if you had to go
on the show like what would your my
strange addiction be
oh i feel like
oh it would be gum it would be
i would say that i feel like if i
explain why okay this is a thing
guys i know this sounds really bad but i
tend to get a little anxious
so when i chew gum i don't just chew
like one piece
i chew like six no no no 11 or 12
at one time no no sophia what's the most
pieces of gum you put in your mouth this
is that one time i had like nine
but that's that i said six is my limit
when i'm really anxious
11. no sophia i did probably as a joke
but i feel like if i had to go extreme
with the show
this is what would happen i would be
having thousands of thousands of flavors
of gum everywhere
it would just be all these canisters and
i'd be just chewing them all the time
and then i feel like i'd be that person
i love my gum so much i'd stick it on a
wall of gum
that would be my strange addiction i
feel like i'm not like a gum
that is so accurate for you right don't
you think that was probably but i'm not
kidding you
if you're ever out and about and you see
sophia never offer her your gun
because she will chew the entire pack in
one sitting it is so
juicy can you help me figure that out i
don't know
my strange addiction probably like
bleaching my hair off or
um oh i know what it'd be it would be
biotin gummies oh it was green
okay oh this is a funny one um this
chick has been growing hair everywhere
i'm like a sasquatch she says she has
hair sticking out of her nose
stop i want any female or male listeners
out there hopefully you understand what
i'm saying
you know those multivitamin gummies like
ali makes them nature's bounty makes
them
they taste really good right it tastes
really good so
the serving size for the amount of
biotin that you're supposed to have per
day
is like 3 000 to 5 000 milligrams right
yeah that's one serving fine which is
healthy
i consume per day
anywhere between 36 to 42
000 milligrams of biotin did you just
hear that
do you how much biotin that is which
okay
do not do that if you're a first-time
biotin user because
stomach is steel it's steel now no no
she had stomach issues
and now she's developed built like an
immunity
to biotin
and we can't wait to look together
should we talk about um who we're
bringing on today
okay you guys we have such a fun guest
on today she is so badass
she is so intuitive and i think she
brought out things that
even christine and i didn't notice or
realize like we have realizations within
the conversation
it's so great i think i definitely
needed to hear this i know you
took a lot of pages out of her book it's
for anyone that
has gone through relationship problems
abandonment issues vulnerability issues
and we just
dissect all of all of it and you realize
that it is all about starting with you
so let's hear about
how you can get to that great core self
and
better you fix your relationships so
stay tuned
this woman is the go to authority for
those who have suffered heartbreak and
are ready to live
unapologetically and attract an
open-hearted
ideal relationship she's an intimacy
expert best-selling author
and host of the podcast intimate
conversations
we have
i love you already your energy oh my god
ordinary
thank you you don't have to give credit
to the red bull but thank you
okay whatever it takes sister right
we're so excited to have you on because
if anyone's a true listener of the unwax
podcast
they know that we are so bad in the
dating
love life you can see every department
it's our favorite topic to talk about
and i
when we were thinking about what to talk
about we had almost too many things we
had so many things and the fact that we
have an expert like yourself here
is just amazing so yeah perfect this is
one of three or one of 30. i'll i got
your best let's keep talking about my
god
i'm so excited so i think we should sort
of kick things off because sophia and i
the way that we go about dating well
maybe i don't know why don't
do you want to maybe say tell us a
little bit about yourself and what you
do we can go from there
oh whatever you want whatever dance you
want yeah i want to hear about it like
what did you get how did you start into
this like what got you into
relationship advice and now yeah
spiritually though
i can swear right oh yeah yeah okay so i
was really [ __ ]
up and the only one in common with all
my relationships was me
that's how i got into it because i was
willing to go you know the blaming thing
doesn't work
i must be doing something that's
creating all these relationships and
what i realized was i was so
insecure on the inside and i didn't want
to admit it because like i'm an ivy
league grad
you know i've modeled all over the world
like i had all these i don't want anyone
to know
that i am like so insecure and terrified
okay this is just me i can feel her
energy she's just like oh my god
i'm like kidding i'm sweating i'm like
tensing up okay go on yes
yeah so so that's good so you have the
bravery to acknowledge it that's the
first step
but normally what we do when we first
acknowledge that we're a hot mess
is we i call it like little you like
little you inside
and she's a hot mess and you're like
shut up and you hit her with a
toothbrush
and you shove her in the closet so that
nobody knows and you just do the
spiritual bypass and you pretend you're
perfect right i'm perfect
well it catches up with you it catches
up with you catches up with like 3am
when you are afraid like what if i act
what if all of this doesn't work out and
i literally die alone one day
yeah everybody knows i'm a fraud and
they're all and i'm humiliated
to be found out like there's all these
fears
one of the first steps you gotta do is
when that little you speaks up you gotta
put down the two by four
give her a hug and say hey
you have every right to feel this way
sweet thing you had such a
happen to you grow up when you were
growing up you have every right to be
scared
you have every right to be ashamed i got
it and instead of trying to fix
you just give compassion you give
listening
and then all of a sudden if you do it
often enough she's like
really you're not going to be a [ __ ] to
me and be mean to me really yeah
love me and here's the deal i love you
without condition
when you go in if you go in and go hey
little you you're so scared
change well that's saying you don't like
the way she is that's saying the way
right
okay that's not right unconditional
that's conditional
right you gotta go in to that closet
that you shoved her in
you gotta throw away the key okay yeah
well i'm willing to love you as you
are even if you never change for
eternity wow
okay exactly but that's the hardest part
is
the acknowledgement of it i think more
than just like saying that
it's like really showing i have so many
questions already
go off so that i've been there
3 a.m i can't sleep my mind is going
bananas thinking about every
conversation that i've had with this
person thinking about
how they treated me i i feel bad for
myself i always get the bad ones blah
blah blah
all this stuff yeah but is it a
reflection of me
because i attract people based off of
how much i love myself
yeah i'm sorry but yeah yeah [ __ ] yeah
that's the twenty-two no it's okay
yeah okay the inside always creates the
outside
every single time these people that say
i always attract emotionally unavailable
guys i'm like
that means you're emotionally
unavailable to little you
okay so if there's a separation on the
inside there will be a separation on the
outside and if there's a homecoming
of compassion understanding it's okay
you're a hot mess it's okay that we need
another shot of tequila in a hot bath
that's okay we're gonna get a little one
yeah there's a oneness on the inside
you'll start to notice on the outside
you don't need to be all perfect
and you can just be yourself you can
have bravery and speak up
you can have healthy boundaries and say
thank you but no thank you and then a
real quality person
arrives on the outside because you have
a quality relationship with you
all of you the wobbly hearts
all the parts on the inside right that's
so interesting because
it seems like such an easy idea like
love yourself and then those will around
you will love you but it's so hard it's
almost like you have to nurture this
like
little fragile ego that lives inside of
everyone well i'm 50. i've been at this
for a while so yeah it takes a while
you are i would have your fifth year
thank you you're beautiful oh my gosh
but i
i think that's why so many people
probably connect to you and relate to
you and understand
these because you are really hitting the
head on then is it the head on the nail
right
yes that quote where yeah tomatoes i
don't know
but you really are hitting the point
where you have to really accept
your past the things that make you who
you are
to go forward and find that healthy
relationship with yourself
and others and everything is really
spiritual it's all the energy
it's all the things that you put out
there that you get back and your
reactions
are things that are hap things that
happened in the past i mean what have
you
seen with a lot of people that you've
talked to throughout like your your
career that is the most common trend
with people that they struggle with when
it comes to like
getting into with their emotions or
really understanding the core of the
problem
yeah they don't know how to navigate
intensity like we have no problem
navigating the intensity of an orgasm
like bring it we're like i could do that
however the intensity of pain sadness
fear oh no no i can't do that but that's
actually a misunderstanding
it's the same spectrum it's the same
spectrum here's the pleasurey place
here's the painful place it's just all
intensity take the meaning off of it
lean in to the pain go with your mind's
eye
see little you she's scared don't hit
her
love her okay cry with her she's scared
be scared with her dive into the pool it
only takes me
five seconds one potato two potato three
potatoes yeah i'm actually we got this
it's gonna be fine three patio
we're gonna make it i love you yeah yeah
and then all of a sudden the emotion
passes and here's the thing
here's a very geeky science thing i'm
kind of a geek energy can't be created
or destroyed
only shifted so that fear you cannot
get rid of but you can be an alchemist
and through loving
holding breathing staying in your body
not just
eating with facebook or another glass of
whatever like stay in it just five
seconds
yeah it'll transform integrate emerge
from pain into okay i'm okay calmness
from sheep into okay i can be an
allowance
from fear to okay i got this
and then when this new energy it's not
just like a thought
it's a embodiment and then here's the
other scientific cool thing
when you've done that integration and
there's a new way of literally feeling
in your body like
okay you might not like that might not
prefer this but i'm okay
your brain turns on and your intuition
turns on so you
you feel safe inside your skin right
make
wise choices even if he's hot right
so is that the telling sign whether you
can you know whether you're
ready for a relationship or not if
you're able to sort of identify that
well i mean i've been married twice
divorced twice like you learn in every
single relationship right now you don't
have to
stay single until you're quote unquote
perfect because there is no person but
you got to be willing to do the work
in any place that you're in if you're in
a relationship do the work if you're
single do the work you got to just be
through the work and be
raised this is a path of bravery but
yeah it's a vibration
so if you're vibrating low self-abuse
self-criticism
blaming whining criticism all that kind
of stuff you're going to attract your
same vibration
someone who will criticize you okay this
is me in a relationship i often attract
people that
i know aren't great for me but i know
that i can fix
and i've sort of figured this out
recently and maybe you can help me a
little bit
i like to have people that are you know
wounded and broken
and i will put them back together to
distract
myself from my own problems
yeah thank you you don't want to step
like a big girl and put your big girl
panties on
right so why is it so i i often attract
so
those are the type of guys that i
attract how would you describe them um
[ __ ] right right i mean like you
know the guys that she attracts it
the thing about you is that you want
someone that
is older that is mature that has their
own [ __ ] going on
but the thing is is that they're so much
about themselves and have so many
they're so their egos are so large that
they don't even consider
your feelings so you're almost going for
am i dating a narcissist i'm not dating
anyone but do i date narcissists that
would be a pretty nice description of
one
but here we go yeah if we go back to the
core
motivation like on the outside the ego
says oh they're
older they've got it together et cetera
but the wound is who's actually running
the show every single day
probably wants if you want to fix them
so that you're what
needed appreciated wanted yes
that yes i that's what it is oh my god
that's what it is
stop right there so all that desire to
be needed wanted approved up and
appreciated
stop seeking it turn it and give it to
yourself
so that you're whole and then you're
like nope narcissist
nope sociopaths nope i updated all of
them
all of the the buried all of them
you know what i think a really good way
to start is straight to the basics and i
know cincinnati have a really
big debate with this as when we play
hard to get or when we're first
talking to a guy or getting into our own
approaches are so different
my approach is more and i know this is
something that i need to work on is that
i do believe in playing games i know
that sounds bad but like let me
explain is that i do that whole thing
where
i don't always give them a hundred
percent i'm always being almost overly
independent doing weights five hours
but i do like to kind of i think that's
also my insecurity where i try to keep a
wall up
and i don't like to be she's we're so
opposite like she's the one that
tells them how she feels i'll dive head
first into the shallow
end of love i'm like let's go for it and
i'm the opposite where i'm like i need
to play these games
because i need to see if they can get
through all my trials and then once they
get to the final round
if they love me first before i love them
but i don't have to feel so how do we
find this happy medium
say that one more time though that was
really say that one more time if they
love me
first then what then i can love them and
so i play these games
until almost the point where they get
mad at me they go you know actually i
did care about you but i don't want to
be with you because i don't know how you
feel
and so you played with me the whole time
so notice where you're looking for
safety
yeah outside if they so and so and jump
through all my hoops i get to be safe on
the inside so who has the power you
or them let's see i'm a control freak
though yeah i i can trust
you i do have i have a problem accepting
love as in like i don't like things that
i can't control so and that's the
biggest thing is that when you're in the
beginnings of a relationship
you really have to be almost vulnerable
to the fact that you could get hurt this
person could
not answer your texts and maybe the game
needs to be played right what would you
say is like the right game to play or
like the correct way to go into a new
relationship that is the healthiest
because let's be honest men don't like
an easy game they want they want a
little bit of a chase
sometimes the difference between the
game of chasing
and uh self-worth to see if they
show up and honor you so if you're
coming from
i'm gonna call it empty so safety isn't
on the inside
because here's the like memo life's
uncertain have you have you figured that
one out yet
yeah can't control [ __ ]
no better ego wants to pretend we can
we'll play games we'll do all this kind
of stuff so i can somehow feel safe on
the inside when my circumstances line up
on the outside which allows people to
use you
and you use others too yeah yep
same same the same uh solution for both
of you
go inside and to the little one inside
who's so scared to
let go of control who doesn't face
because you've been avoiding her
right and playing games with them out
there you're kind of playing games with
her inside and go inside and go hey
life's uncertain that kind of sucks
but i got yeah got your back right goes
we break up we stay together either way
i will be with you forever i got you
and you're pretty cool even though
you're myself like so you have the
safety on the inside
so you don't have to play games on the
outside you can be with
life is uncertain and you don't need to
play games from manipulation
but you have factories you're not
needing
healthy boundaries yes it's like hey i
worked all day
i i had a great day working i really
looked forward to texting you yeah yeah
yeah but it's not a game it's not a
manipulation from empty right
i think sophia and i yes i think sophie
and i come from
well let's just test him and see if he's
going to hurt me
and like we're just trying to do
everything possible to avoid
the pain and you avoid it and i ignore
the flags
why do i do that either way your if your
point of view creates your reality right
and your
question is i don't want him to hurt me
what are we focused on
focusing on hurt being hurt what is
eventually going to happen you're going
to get hurt get hurt
because we're going to work that's so
true that's so simple
oh focus on god potentially getting hurt
you're gonna get hurt
because that's what you're putting out
there yeah and that's who you're being a
little bit scared
pretending to be cool yeah yes
ask a different question what is it
gonna take for me to be honored
right those eyes will look for behaviors
of a man that's honoring if he doesn't
text him back
if he's looking at all these other
chicks when you're out with them like
you notice he's not honoring you so you
you're done i need can you can you tell
me some ways that guys do honor
girls so i can notice them because
sometimes guys will do sweet things like
that and they'll just
go right over my head and then they're
like you know
take notice of the efforts i'm making so
that you're saying you don't take notice
of all their kindness
sometimes no i do but sometimes they do
something to honor you
and you know you kind of just like let
it go by and they're like wait that was
a big deal for me to do for you
what are some things that guys do that
they honor their women so i can like
keep a mental note next time that
happens even deeper than what you just
asked
where you're looking or missing it is i
would say chin
up you're you're probably super smart
you're cognitively analyzing what
they're doing and you're getting
miles an hour trying to figure it out so
you can be safe that's not where your
power is
your power is in your uh-huh it's in
your [ __ ]
it's in your sacred yoni it's in your
gut your instincts they you
know before thought is knowing knowing's
first thought is second heart is first
your yoni will go crunch it all up it's
like just
if you don't know go to the bathroom on
a date just sit there
okay sweet sister vagina we talked to
them
i don't know for sure for sure you just
say no i talked to her
and she's like he's scary but he's
really hot he has a lot of money but i
don't trust him
your gut will be like i feel nauseous
right really hot but i don't
wait so do you listen to your gut or
your yoni both
both okay okay okay
never lie this applies to us all the
time
yes you know what it just sounds like to
me that it just like just hit me right
now is that
when you have that relationship with
your [ __ ] or in your gut and then
also with your mind and you go into a
first state
and if you're being that person right
off the bat
it is really easy to tell who this
person is yeah
right off the bat as well thank you yeah
that's the thing i think people forgot
is that
when you put no i guess it doesn't have
to be your guard down but just
when you're really in tune with what you
want who you
are and you go into the state with an
open mind
yeah then you will see the red flags or
that
attraction on attraction or that
hesitation or that allure
instantly yeah yeah in fact the biggest
misunderstanding is that vulnerability
is somehow like a weakness
when you're totally open yeah you know
everything you sense
everything you see everything it's
intense i'll tell you it's intense
because you're right
can't control [ __ ] but you know you know
and so that's actually your superpower
but vulnerability is it's
it's hard for a lot of people and it's
hard for me to because i'm like okay
well a lot of people use my kindness for
weakness and sort of switch it on me and
and then they'll use it against me later
so how how can someone like me that's
like
i don't want to be vulnerable because if
you know who i really am
then you might not like it like how do i
sort of put that guard down
okay your safety and your worth is an
inside job
your accomplishments come and go right
your youth will come and go
everything will come and go money like
whatever it's all going to come and go
that has nothing most people like
collapse their worth and their
accomplishments on the same thing
they're actually separate
so if your worthiness is based on the
date going well or him
liking you you're [ __ ] so take your
power back
and your worth is your worth is your
worth end of story is it on your face
jiggle on your ass money no like beauty
whatever it's like
never ever will so you go into a date
vulnerable even if they see
the real you and they judge you who the
[ __ ] cares right
y'all take that judgment and put it
behind you i know i care too
their opinion has nothing to do with
your worth
no it might spin might sting no it's
true
it's true it's true that's the problem i
think i'm finally realizing this now at
22
i seek approval and validation from all
of the men that i go out with if they
tell me i'm pretty then i'll believe
that i'm pretty
if they say oh you have a nice body then
i think i have a good body
and then if they do the opposite then i
start seeing things that i never saw
about myself so you're right i gotta
it's hard for you to do that but it's
like you think that's only just your
insecure
like mindset with things but they're
always interesting
as well because you can only attract
that kind of person based on your
vibration
and the more you feel the more work you
do on yourself giving yourself
appreciation
yeah your self acknowledgement and that
that builds inner confidence
and over time it builds sass builds the
sexy irresistible
like it factor oh that is the best
transition
we wanted to ask that okay speaking of
sexy yeah you wrote a book called
how to be and stay sexy which is just
please drown me in your wisdom right now
drown me in it so first of all i guess
the first question is
tell us how to be sexy or anyone
listening
don't give a [ __ ] about what anybody
thinks about you but not from this
arrogant i don't care about you
but literally my worth has nothing to do
with you it's like talking about where
like it doesn't matter
right so it's about first off it's like
i my worth is inside out 100 of the time
we don't wait to feel yummy delicious
orgasmic till he whips it out
like we don't wait for that right take
love with life every day
good morning life what do you have for
me penetrating my morning life
what miracle do you have for me right
right yeah we let the sunshine penetrate
us we let the bath
you know ooze us we we slow down and
savor that
sip of our coffee in the morning we make
everything delicious
yeah feel this this yummy energy
being alive that's like the easier part
of like adorning your body beautifully
and just falling madly in love with you
not waiting around for attention or sex
to like self pleasure masturbate like
just like it's to be delicious
because because right so it's almost
like
viewing everything you do like glass
half full
and so so if you're gonna better
yourself in the world it's
all from inside so if i want to be sexy
it's not like i don't need to wear
lingerie and have
stripper heels on it and thigh high
boots and whatever it's all
you can you can the outer expression of
your inner
you might feel like elf pajamas one day
and might feel like thigh high boots the
next
yeah you can make that sexy you honor
you
right how can every moment be
making love with the universe moment how
can i suck the marrow out of everything
even praise my sisters as opposed to be
competitive with them
even that sexy like girl yeah you're
good
yeah like that kind of idea as well um
makes you feel super super sexy and then
also any shame you have around sexy
because society teaches us to use our
sex appeal as a
weapon as a manipulation yeah that's
true you got to knock that [ __ ] off
it has to stop it has to stop yeah
a
when i was like listening to some of
your podcasts and i was reading a lot of
like
the um even like i was reading some of
the comments and things
and i was thinking about my friends and
what was one thing that they all kind of
had in common not all of them
but i've seen a lot and even with her
friends is
and this is kind of sometimes like me
but not really is this fear of
abandonment
and i can see a lot of my girlfriends
and i hope they're not
pointing themselves out thinking like oh
she's talking about me but i'm talking
about the girls that
are in these relationships that are not
healthy
that are not the best and they just
stick with it
and they don't ever get out of it
because they don't maybe think their
worth is enough or or the ones that
aren't in relationships and
have a difficult time being single yeah
aka
me well it's exactly it's like they jump
from relationship to a relationship
and they don't really get them time for
themselves and date themselves in a way
yes yes abandonment like root from where
does it start is it from home life is it
from
relationships is it well when we're
young
i call it like the first 40 but you guys
are learning this by 22 apparently but
like the first part of your life you're
wired backwards you're just this little
thing
and when you do it this way you get love
and you do it this way you don't get
love so you keep looking for who do i
need to be to get love on the outside
right
and then you start to feel really out of
control insecure
pretending you're fine when you're not
and you're like okay what's going on
and then you realize i'm wired backwards
so the idea of abandonment is that we've
actually abandoned ourselves
if we were home with ourselves we would
maybe prefer things to go a certain way
but we wouldn't lose our [ __ ]
if it didn't go well and we'd be able to
break up be alone with ourselves
so the best thing that can happen is to
be alone
that is the best spiritual practice
maybe not forever right
yeah that's hard no i don't care good do
it
be willing to do what's hard to have a
life that's easy the cave you feared
to enter holds the treasure that you
seek go into the cave of loneliness
and meet the you that you don't want to
meet yeah
it's essentially this emotional baggage
it's like how do you overcome this
emotional baggage
and stop searching for validation from
everyone else
you validate yourself yeah okay how do
you do that do you look at yourself in
the mirror yeah because it's so
it's easier said than done i think that
people assume that confidence
and salvation you're born with it or
you do it for a day and then you'll feel
it no it's such
a consistent amount of effort every
single day
every single day and it doesn't stop
when you're 50. it gets easier but it
doesn't stop okay
right but very simple practice of how do
you sit in your aloneness
is the breathing thing like the intense
emotion of orgasm no problem but the
intense emotion that i'm alone is not
so i i feel one potato two potato okay
so and then you think of little you you
think of little you and you hold them
you
and you and you acknowledge hey you have
every right to feel alone right now i've
been abandoning you or you
you get into one of my programs and
there's this little you meditation i
should give it to you too it's like 30
minutes long it's amazing but it takes
you solely through coming home to you
until you really feel this oneness
you've got to spend time
journal walk in nature have a hot bath
be alone meditate you've gone can
say today's the day i'm coming home with
myself today i want to find that little
you yeah and
i'm not going to abandon her anymore
yeah how do you
approach this to your friends because
this is my thing is that
they're going to say ah shut up it's
like i did life i guess two questions is
when you notice one of your friends is
in a relationship
or a situation where they should not be
and it's not the healthiest how do you
bring that up to them and then
how do you yourself notice that this
probably isn't the best relationship
maybe it's not the obvious red flags are
swinging everywhere
yeah but you have to it's like hard to
how do you find that within yourself to
go wait this actually
even though it sounds good it's okay the
relationship's fine
know that this isn't the healthiest one
to be in like so how do you approach it
to your friends and then how do you do
it for yourself
okay so your friends lives you're not
their mentor
you're not their teacher you're their
friend so i would invite a way of
communicating where you ask
permission don't give unsolicited advice
because it'll be taken defectively or
like judgment
permission you say hey i love you so
much
that i have some insights i could be
wrong but i have some insights just
because i care about you
would you like to hear them and if not i
love you just as much
and if they say yes if they hear what
i'm seeing and i think you deserve
better and i love you more and if you
need support
read this book talk to this counselor or
do whatever because i
care about you right so if it's
permission first it'll go a lot better
and then you can give them guidance
they might say no i don't want to hear
from you and then you've got to sit in
the fire of that discomfort and watch
their demise and love them anyways
so there's nothing you just got to let
them figure it out for themselves
everybody has their own journey if
they're a child mother them if you're
their mother but if they're an adult
let them be an adult and find their own
way even if they hit against the wall a
million times
they're learning there's something
they're learning and don't uh
don't fix it's sort of like cutting the
the butterfly out of the cocoon too soon
they die
yeah right i mean i had to do this with
my own son
he's now like this 6'5 kid but when he
was little and he oh
i hate you because they wouldn't i
wouldn't tie his freaking shoelaces for
him i'd like to let him go you can do it
i hate you and i had to i could just tie
them for him he'd be like
yeah five years old not able to tie his
shoes if i did that right
right yeah sometimes being a friend is
just being willing to love them with
your heart open
and watch them suffer and love them
anyways that's true i love
that and then also the part two you're
in the relationship
and you've probably had friends that
have come up to you said i don't like it
or
your parents don't like it um how do you
like what what's a tell sign to know
that like maybe i need to step back for
this and how do you come to terms with
like
approaching that situation yeah so first
like if you listen to people not
everybody's opinion is right so take it
with a grain of salt
but if like everybody in your life is
saying something have a look and then
again
alone time draw a line down the center
of the page you and your little
and you're like big like when it's you
talking use your right hand or if you're
your dominant hand and then when it's
little you talking use your subconscious
or your like left hand
and go so how do you actually feel about
this relationship
i don't like them oh i haven't slowed
down to listen to you
i should say yeah that's actually wow
yeah i don't even think that's so true
number one is slow down and listen step
number two once the truth is there
you've got two
two paths yeah every relationship can
grow i help couples
heal they also help couples consciously
uncouple
so not one is better than the other but
truth
yeah truth always wins so first you
gotta have your own truth
second before you throw in the towel
have a conversation with this person
sandwich the bread is like hey i'm so
grateful that we are dating and growing
together middle of the sandwich
permission
hey can i speak from my heart i'm
experiencing
um loneliness or that we don't seem to
be on the same page or that whatever the
challenge is
end of the sound what are your thoughts
so if you do it like that with kindness
and they're like [ __ ] you okay they
don't want to grow
move on couples that grow together stay
together
right right so it's almost like you know
the answers
already but once you see it in writing
it sort of solidifies it
yeah you said you said that you also
helped couples
uncouple yeah and so sophie and i always
go back and forth with this idea that is
closure or
if your partner wants closure is it
overrated
like is it even necessary closure
yeah my definition of closure is did you
get the lesson because if you didn't get
the lesson you're going to attract the
same lesson and another guy
so what if you feel because i sometimes
sophia and i both sometimes feel like
we made our point clear we said x y and
z
there's not much more we can say but a
week later they're like i still need
closure
at that point do you meet with them and
are willing to keep
sort of nurturing them until they feel
okay
no you're not responsible for another's
well-being they need to that very same
thing that you we talked about earlier
we don't want to sit in our own fire
yeah
and rise like a phoenix neither do they
so a very
pleasant so how do you how do you
approach that if they're like oh i still
need to i still need to reach out to you
what do you ignore them do you say
i'm sorry no more i do one response and
then i ignore them i say
um i hear what you're saying i am
complete i wish you all the best on your
relationship journey
writing this down no because it i think
a lot
no more after that yeah yeah because
it's this is the whole issue is that
it's not they don't need closure from
you they just need closure from
themselves
they're not confronting what they're
feeling and i think that that's why i
believe
closure is sometimes overrated i think
that there obviously is a reason for the
relationship ending and then you both
sides know
basically what's going on and even if
you explain it over and over and over
even if the person wasn't set breaking
up with the person for a specific reason
or if it was kind of more of their
themselves needing that release
you have to understand like it's not you
it's or it's not me
i need to figure out how i can move on
without having
another person once again validate thank
you my emotions
thank you yeah yeah yeah it's like
that's the it's all about validation i
feel like this whole game this whole
dating thing is like
do you validate my emotions do you
validate the relationship
am i good enough for you and that does
not
it does that's not what a relationship
is about the relationship
needs to be a partnership a relationship
needs to be an individual
so thank you yeah yeah you're kidding me
my mind is like
racing right now two empties seeking
validation you complete me
then you have to stay so you can keep
completing me and if you go yeah then i
will be complete okay that's
unhealthy two holes come together i call
that heart rate that's the name of my
dating app partners when two holes come
together
the whole is greater than the sum of the
part because one whole and one hole they
don't need each other
they complement not complete complement
one another
so a great exercise in completing
relationships
is to say thank you forgive see that
word forgive is in there thank you for
giving me
this experience because i learned i
discovered i evolved
i i let go of i stepped into i no longer
i always will
you just keep going down 10 or 15 times
thank you gratitude is the highest
vibration but we have to integrate it
hopefully you learned a lot and if you
do and you do that work
thank you for giving me this experience
of being betrayed being cheated on
being left being boasted being ditched
being gaslight whatever
because i learned i was seeking
validation
thank you and now go and do that anymore
thank you exactly
i learned that now ow and then you won't
make maybe you will make the same
mistake again
you wrote a new book called finding the
one
is bs becoming the one is brilliant and
beautiful
by the way all of your book titles are
so good so good so
this is awesome so there's this whole
thing sort of happening
in the media everyone's like i have a
twin flame twin flame do you think
that there can only be one quote-unquote
twin flame for each
now you're shaking your head now tell me
why because
i'm at one with the universe at all
times i'm [ __ ] the universe
the universe is [ __ ] me i'm in
oneness how does it feel
let me know i'm not okay not all the
time i have my moments okay i have my
fetal position
yeah i eat a bag of chips in in the bath
like i have those moments but
but in general if i choose and i come
back into my presence there is no
separation between you and me
there's no separation between me and the
universe there's no separation there's
no separation
and so for you to have oh you complete
me
you are my twin flame yeah way too much
of your power away to one individual
to make you somehow enough so i believe
there are whole mates
i do believe in that i do believe
there's homemade relationships where
you ignite something in me that's
dormant and i ignite something in you
that's dormant i'm a stand for your
enlightenment you being the most fully
[ __ ] self
expressed fully alive yummy
person right different than this empty
empty until we find each other that to
me is
a red flag i feel like there's a
there's the one for every part of your
life like
and not not in a sense like different
maybe phases but i think there could be
the one that teaches you
how to grow and explore new things about
yourself sensually or confidently and
then there's another
one that makes you grow into a person
more
ambitious and career driven and there's
a one that
maybe is more of your emotional softer
side and
i'm not saying date like 400 people and
then you'll get a little bit here and
there
but i've never been a person that's like
um i'll
find the one really early on and like
that's though if you
you want to die and if that's the way
that obviously people have been raised
in different situations and their
mindsets are different
beautiful like if you're happy and it's
a healthy relationship
great but that's what i do agree with
that i think that
there is something to be learned from a
lot of relationships yeah one
isn't always going to be like the one
it's going to be the one that if
this is at this moment in your life and
i feel like the one that you want to
marry
is usually the person that is like the
one that you're growing with continually
it's the friendship
it's yeah because it's like when you get
older you're not going to be with
like the hot stuff when you're 80 years
old like you're both going to get like
quite gray and old but
um that's kind of like i know that for
me like there's relationships that i
want as the one
at that time that's going to i know that
it's going to make make me grow
what are you saying we can't find the
one right now not the one that i'm not
wearing
babies i said the one in terms of like
different scenarios
i just think that if i tried to find the
one right now at this
point in my life it would be disaster
waiting to happen yeah well the the name
of the book finding the one is [ __ ]
is like as you said finding this one
person forever
really the one we're looking for is us
becoming the one is one with us and when
we're the one
yeah we're the one we're the punchline
he's not the one
we're the one yep thank you and when
you're one with yourself
this phase of your life you're into sex
this phase of your life you're in a
business this phase of your life into
having kids this phase of your life
you're into
spiritual practice maybe you find one
who evolves like you do like that yeah
and you stay together because every face
continues to evolve
i want to ask one last thing to sort of
wrap up the show
yeah we have been talking a lot about
what we can do as individuals
to attract a certain type of someone but
i want to know from your years of
experience and knowledge
what do men really want like the things
that
things that we can improve on say if
we're on a date like things that men
want and don't ask for
okay so i was on a stage once and there
was 25 women and maybe like 300 men and
women
and they voted who do you want to [ __ ]
who do you just want to have sex with
there was a vote and then the other vote
was who do you want to
be stuck with on a desert island for 20
years because they would have your back
and believe in you
two very different flavors of the
feminine yeah yeah one very sexy one
very
um awake inspiring goddess right yeah
i won in both categories it was very
strange
and we unpacked this for about an hour
and a half after
and the men said there's something about
this one because
the other woman that they wanted to have
sex with was like your age and look like
you
okay i'm old what do they want to have
sex with me for
she's having pleasure in her body and i
want in
she's not having she's not being sexy to
manipulate me she's not
doing it to be better than the other
women she's just having pleasure being
alive in her body
and i want him so one of the ways that
men are attracted to us is when we have
pleasure
being alive being ourselves that's why
i'm staying like that
and have things we're not doing it for
any other reason that our own joy
so that's one thing they love about us
the other thing is they then they're
like why did
all the women in the audience were like
why do you want to spend 20 years on an
island with her
and the men said i don't know what it is
but if i lost my job
she wouldn't cut my balls off i don't
know what it is i just know i can't feel
it
and here's the capacity of open heart in
the face of anything
vulnerable in the face of anything when
we as women close our heart when he does
something
inappropriate that hurts us we
emasculate them through
anger yeah okay yeah and then they don't
trust
us and they don't spend 20 years on a
desert island with us yeah
they don't marry us okay we open our
heart even though they just lost their
job and we're afraid if they're going to
pay the bills or not
yeah we open our heart and we say i i
[ __ ] love you get out there and get a
job
and [ __ ] my brains out i love you i
believe in you we're still intense
but here's the difference we're fearful
we're fierce love we're not anger
and that skill set as a woman when we're
afraid
not to close and emasculate but to open
and invite their grandeur
even though we're scared why because
back to the beginning of the
conversation
because we have our own back we have an
intimate relationship with ourselves we
are one with little you
but that's why finding the one is
[ __ ] becoming the one
is brilliant and beautiful little you
heart open
grandeur of a goddess heart open in the
face of anything pleasure just from
being alive
always yeah love it we'll bring you guys
you oh my god that was so well said
yeah wow oh my god this conversation i
feel like
i need to sit for a few hours and with a
glass of wine and just process
everything and i think i'm going to be a
better person tomorrow
i don't know about you i can't wait i
mean thank you so
much for coming on the show today like
this is one of those conversations that
you know sometimes you need a tune-up i
needed to hear this so i so appreciate
you taking the time and doing it you've
just blessed our listeners with giving
them such
yeah crucial information that you know
sometimes you all you'll find tune up
and for the listeners that want more be
sure to find her new book finding the
one is bs becoming the one is brilliant
and beautiful
and look out for her new coming soon
exclusive dating app and intimacy
training
all rolled into one called heartmates
coming soon
please tell everyone where they can find
all of your videos yeah thank you
heartmates.app it's the dating app the
intimacy training and live
weekly conscious communication so you
get to practice those communications i
said tell me something you want to
understand we practice that every single
week yeah
so that's heartmates.app and then my
website is my name alanapratt.com all
the books all the meditations
all sorts of great resources are there
and thank you for being so awake
at such a young age to be willing to do
the work
and share it with the world i i honor
you and it's been a privilege
yeah oh my god thank you so much oh my
god you're
amazing i mean this was such an
eye-opening conversation so thank you so
much
you're so welcome i'm in love with you
already big high groups
bye bye